oh yeah Tuesday the 25th of September
you're at attention
ready to [__] go you don't saying
who's gonna stop you who's even got the
[__] nerve to stop you today you
don't give a [__] you understand me your
balls are washed your [__] polished
and you don't give a [__] you won't
follow I'm saying here who's gonna come
at you and tell you this some thirty six
years ago get the [__] out of here
most people don't let me with the head
for [__] breakfast three days ago
but that's not how we do it
[__] bang you follow me uncle
Joey in the house of the Tuesday morning
checking in with my [__] savages
making sure you're tip-top Magoo
nobody's [__] with you you got your
goals written down you got your 22
push-ups and your dick is harder than a
[__] missile you understand me
[__] ilan my son and that Chinese
businessman sort of funk and moon I
wouldn't get in one of his [__] self
driving cars you gotta go to the moon
with that [__] [__] get it together
white people but this guy and even white
he's [__] Chinese I'm sitting here
with [__] the best of bourbon trees
you understand me we got some [__]
nug
it's called white buffalo I still got
some of that left over I got this
monster right here who the [__] cares
when it's called it's called death do
you understand me we got this right here
understand I'm not here smoking
susquehanna we were trying to [__]
listen we're just getting together
[__] communicating and letting you
know it's gonna be alright [__] the
world [__] what they're telling you it's
you and me and gets all these
[__] hand-to-hand combat on a
daily you understand me and if your
thought process ain't like that bend
over and Vaseline that [__] cuz I'm
gonna get no better for you look at this
fool muchas muchas we're gonna open up a
nicety for this morning
this thing is sofa super Silver Haze
from urban trees over I'm Ventura
I even smoked their [__] sativas cuz
they put
from planning the rest of these people
give you this jack all right I should
don't do nothing to nobody will give you
bad breath [__] I start up a little
sativa to get the mind going you know
for the for the Gentiles oh I get this
body here good go tell it to some
[__] body you [__] [__] a body I
the [__] out of here I want to see
[__] stars and stripes I want to see
Colin Kaepernick and jumping up and down
during the national anthem going I got
paid [__] I don't know what the [__]
you're talking about there we go a
little super Silver Haze I'm hoping
you're having a great day your family's
beautiful and everything about you is
going great man and listen you're gonna
have bad days you're gonna have good
days but at the end of the week you
believe you put your heart into it they
can all suck your dick
they always do then just sitting there
on the side I'll suck that with yeast
coming out of the side of that [__]
mouth [__] them you run this
[__] they can't stop you wanna
[__] do that they couldn't stop me
and I let back in the seventh grade the
GED I don't gonna stop you
how the [__] that ain't gonna stop you
get up off the [__] couch smoke some
reefer look at yourself in the mirror
and you split the member [__] you
[__] I'm going out there to get
what's belong to me there's an envelope
out there waiting for you just too lazy
to go get you think somebody's my
nothing you're doing give it to you you
lazy sacks of [__] like another
[__] collecting food stamps as a
man well kind of man collects food
stamps and by susquehanna weed and what
the [__] is wrong with people
anyway little sativa to get the morning
started
oh yeah oh yeah anomaly no sativa type
of guy but urban trees those
[__] when I go in there they
they just know they got the devil
package waiting for them you ever have
the devil packet it's like right now you
get [__] now G on that gene Simmons
he's free to come you gonna [__] them in
October and you can get a sphere be a
best man for six grand and hang out with
your [__] like that that's great you
know what I'd rather hang out with the
devil [__] I'm a couple dollars urban
trees [__] from Ventura right down
the block from cryotherapy I killed two
birds with one stone I get reefer then I
go freeze for a couple [__] minutes I
got the pipe I washed it with hot water
I wash my pipe every three to four days
to get the old maluca same thing with
the bunk every time I get to the office
I wipe it down with my saw I smoked
reefer mixed with Lysol what do you
think might look like but who gives a
[__] you don't see me [__] you know
anyway that's it and that's that Boston
Saturday night is sold out I'm sorry
this may be 8 tickets left the [__]
Connecticut on Saturday night on Friday
night I'm ready to go I'm ready to
[__] go I can't wait to get the legal
seafoods and tear those [__] up
[__] Weight Watchers they changed their
name anyway they don't want to offend
fat people wait what the [__] is going
on what the [__] is going on but anyways
got nothing to do with uncle Joey
it's got to do with us and now we're
gonna throw down in Boston then October
11th I head over the West Palm Beach
Florida
do not bring cocaine I am clean and
sober you got a vicodin
you got a butter good reefer slipping in
my hand but no cocaine no heroin no
[__] love that [__] I ain't don't
know that [__] what are we some enjoying
what's with the [__] they're beaten
you smoked us at tea when they say
somebody put a quarter in you let's get
the end of the climb this [__] native
down you're following it
is some tight little brown buds I hung
up my glasses so I don't know the
[__] name with a [__] weeding it
don't matter if I'm smoking it
it's that ain't no [__] such man you
following me that's all you [__] need
to know and then after that we go to
Cleveland to see my man steel [__]
because just cuz he lost no man he ain't
the [__] champion you following me
always remember that just cuz you lose
on me you're not the [__] champion as
long as you put that in your head
you always live another [__] day you
need a roast beef sandwich and you pull
on that left glove and you go back out
there and do the best you [__] can
tremendous if [__] beeps in my ears
you ever smoke weed the hair like [__]
yeah they [__] me that's when you
know you're right then in there you
follow me
and that's it and that's that man it's
nice and simple I just want to touch
base for you the died national nail
podcast is up for you with doing Greg
Fitzsimmons today you'll have that
[__] tomorrow and that's it and then
they our special announcement tomorrow
you'll find that tomorrow [__]
Thursday morning all right for you
Netflix [__] it's coming me am
I happy I'm a way better comic today
than when I was when I taped that
[__] special so it breaks my [__]
heart if you see me today you'll go what
the [__] happened joy bleh
that's what it's all about evolving
changing growing and that's it that's
all like to [__] tell you right now
beside that I'm happy just to be just to
be 55 to be alive and to have you guys
on my corner and still sling and deck
like I'm [__] 28 except what the
[__] handcuffs on what else we
smoking telling anyone what badges
something so we killed this we killed
the super Silver Haze they're so super
surveys are so good the container is
sticky the [__] container this [__]
grew out of the [__] container we
smoked this yeah oh yeah we opened up
with the white buffalo let's smoke some
of this this comes with a warning child
this is what they give you when you have
dimension they throw you in the [__]
Lake
[__] tremendous look at this look at
this look at this [__] thing looks
like one of those people to crazy
haircut
you ever see those black people and get
the crazy [__] haircut machine like
what happened the Afro machine backfired
what happened get your natural order
like Julius Erving and [__] was the
first black dude you seen in the
dictionary what's his name I loved that
[__] guy the first time I said I was
picked I shut that [__] thing I was
scared to death Frederick Douglass
Frederick Douglass is natural it was
like this that [__] put a
flourishing in it he was bumping [__]
like [__] you know anyway
who gets a fun well this is a history
lesson I'm just trying to smoke some
dope with you [__] animals cuz I love
you you think like I'm part yeah I got
[__] going on but about 10:30 by that
time I'll be ready to go 10:30
I gotta make a move right out of 12 then
I got a three baby up and then I got
dinner they all say press the table and
I got a [__] spot at the store so one
minute I'm saying press the table I'm
thinking Jesus for a meal and the next
minute I'm talking about sticking
fingers up your ass and making it smell
it the [__] gate salute
anyway that's how we do it here yeah I'm
saying I give you a hundred percent and
that's it and that's that I'm gonna
[__] die on the stage cuz I'm gonna
be up to have [__] throwing Heat no
more [__] around
normal hold them back I'm going [__]
bananas again I don't even go anywhere
else but the store I was telling these
[__] last night I'm gonna Rogen
and somebody else in middle night
[__] Ari and I told them I just go to
the store now the Marines don't train
nowhere else what are they trained you
know North Carolina don't they that's me
North Carolina is the [__] candy
store from now on
they're metal sharp is metal like a
[__] animal the next time you see Joe
Diaz your eyes are gonna pop out of your
[__] head you're gonna leave their own
one on out of your [__] that because
that's what I plan to do and this [__]
that comes out of my mouth at this point
I'm 55 what do you do what do you then
do you gonna send Ronan Farrow after me
I don't give a [__] that little guy
listened before people live in glass
houses shouldn't tell the [__] stones
I want to view the rest of your creepy
[__] family before you go on busting
other people's career mr. Rowland
[__] foul anyway [__] that little
[__] [__]
yeah always [__] sticking his nose
but don't belong [__]
anyway I'm sorry I get emotional about
that type of [__] making an allegation
is 36 years ago daddy is not was 19
years old you know what I was doing you
don't want to know what I was doing I
wasn't [__] squeezing nobody's
titties but I wasn't no [__] angel
either you follow me but who remembers
if you remember you ain't real if you
remember you ain't real how can you
remember something happen in college and
college is supposed to be eating [__]
Cosby pills and jumping up and down all
sudden you remember 36 years later
suck my dick and call me shorty I was
born in 1940 you follow me and I said
that's that
it's a [__] Tuesday and we're here
how lucky we were here we could be on a
[__] desert island you could be an
African [__] digging [__] blood
blood [__] diamonds we took you up on
top throwing hot water on you or you
could just be in Africa with flies
around but we're here in the United
States or England or what the [__] you
are you eating you're alive so what
you're gonna don't be a problem [__]
kick it [__] get out this stabbed a
[__]
and that's it and be free people always
say to be self talking but I am myself
no no takes years to be yourself when
you be something no coming back you're
like [__] Draco and [__] what's
that movie Bruce Lee some way that shot
whatever the [__] that movie is there
ain't no coming back anyway I don't know
about you but I'm stoned to the gills
that was the purpose of this little tape
typed a face-to-face with you
[__] to let you know to your
face that I [__] love you thank you
for having my back without you and have
[__] guts and that's it remember it's
Tuesday oh yeah oh I'm not a little much
that completely sorry mind your [__]
business but always remember that there
didn't get my mother and mother all gone
totally oh sorry they didn't get my oil
book I'm missing my raw power pinga
yesterday was about last [__]
birthday I dressed him white
I had the coconuts and I'm saying it was
a beautiful [__] denim I don't forget
[__] I don't forget about you
[__] thank you for coming to
the shows thank you for selling amount
thank you for giving me a [__] chance
I love you [__] with all my
heart
don't forget special announcement
tomorrow you get to find out that I
thought I thought that and that's it and
that's that have a great day be safe
keep your eyes [__] open cuz you
never [__] know and get ready to rock
[__] ain't nobody giving away
nothing for free especially that play